من أنت ، أنا جيف بيزوس ، ما هو
ادعائك للشهرة ومؤسس موقع
amazon.com الذي بدأ
كمكتبة لبيع الكتب عبر الإنترنت منذ آلاف السنين من الآن ،
سوف ينظر الناس إلى الوراء ويقولون لقد أصبحت
إمبراطورية افتراضية أمازون هي حقًا
الأكثر نجاحًا  شركة في
تاريخ الأعمال تقول
الكثير إنها بداية التجارة الإلكترونية يا
رفاق لم تعرفوا حتى إذا كان هذا الشيء
سيعمل ، فلدينا غريزة جيدة جدًا
إذا قدمت أفضل خدمة عبر الإنترنت
سيأتي الناس
[موسيقى]
هذه شركة تريد التحكم
في البنية التحتية مع استمرار انخفاض أسعار أجهزة الكمبيوتر ،
وسنضع
ابتكاراتنا فوق ذلك ، ومن المعقول
أن تعرف أمازون أنك أفضل مما
تعرف نفسك ،
أليكسا ، إنها في منازلنا ، إذا كان الناس
يثقون في أنها لن تفعل ذلك  أن يتم استخدامها ضدهم
بطريقة لا تسمح لهم
مطلقًا في متناول أيدينا ، حيث استحوذت Amazon Web
Services على الويب بشكل أساسي خلال
عقد من الزمان ، حيث يمنحك هذا القدر من القوة
وقفة مما يمثل استجابة
مهمة  نحن ندرك ذلك ،
والآن يغذي اقتصادنا أمازون هي الشركة
الأمريكية الثانية التي تبلغ قيمتها تريليون دولار ،
والآن أصبحت الشركة الآن تساوي ما يساوي
الاقتصاد الأسترالي
بالكامل أمازون كبير جدًا
، ولا أعتقد أن أمازون كبيرة جدًا.  يعتقدون
أن لديهم قوة احتكارية ، لقد
أصبحت أمازون من الأنواع الغازية ، لذا
تعتقد أنه يجب تفكيك أمازون
أوه 100٪ رحلة إنها
معجزة عمل وقائد على عكس أي شخص آخر ،
هذا هو القمر الأزرق ، سألت الناس في
أمازون يستيقظون خائفين كل صباح
استيقظ وخائفًا ، خائفًا
من عملائنا ، هؤلاء هم الأشخاص الذين
يتعين علينا الانتباه إلى تقرير خاص لشبكة CNN ،
يمكنني أن أضمن لكم شيئًا واحدًا
سيكون ممتعًا في عصر أمازون
[موسيقى]